The Joe Rogan experience I do believe has a lot of benefits to it and I started
because I had major injuries and I didn't want to actually take the pain pills I
was being prescribed for my surgeries,
so that's why I started investigating weed and marijuana and I would help that
to calm me down.
I want her to talk to you about that because that's another issue that I think
is really important because I keep hearing about fighters that are having
problems with pain pills.
I think a hundred percent people are going to be back to back.
Major fucking surgeries lined up under my Brooklyn job or client ankle.
Tore up my knee.
I had my neck surgery.
I had like a couple of good ones will my hand a couple of times.
So I've had multiple surgeries so one of the things they started getting major
injuries and then getting surgeries and I didn't want to take the pain pills.
Although I did take some of them and I like when I broke my jaw I was taking a
liquid,
some kind of liquid pain pill.
I don't know what it was,
but that's what started my venture into wheat,
so it was just to get through the night so I could sleep,
but it does fuck in my memory man,
like I was having like the next day I have an issue like holding combinations
for these guys and stuff and just not remembering dates and stuff.
So it did fuck with me personally.
I call it my memory and I don't think it's for everybody because I'm very,
very high strong and try to get shit done all not trying to get shit done on it
all the time.
So I think if somebody else has already killed predisposed to be a slight bit
lazy,
this is not for you 100 percent either way.
It's not for everyone makes him differently though.
He can enjoy time.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Yeah.
It's like a reverse effect.
Like most people get stolen the sit on the couch,
they'll get hungry and not want to go start doing combos and shit.
This guy's shadow.
You
know what?
I figured things out about my body when I'm high,
I,
I figured out certain stretches that I need,
like I feel like,
you know what,
I'm tight right here,
like I've,
I've figured shit out.
And then as you're feeling your body more,
I be like,
you know what,
I got to incorporate that more.
And then like certain techniques,
like kicking techniques,
like I've gone over them high and I like feel the weight transfer,
better speech,
speaking to Haydn,
that shit.
Listen to this.
There was a dude in China that got arrested.
He,
uh,
he went to jail and because he convinced a girl that she,
her vagina was haunted and that he had to get rid of the ghost with his penis.
So they arrested him for this.
They,
they arrested him after he claimed that he get rid of it.
The paranormal enthusiasts allegedly charged $3,250 to perform the sexism.
What a brilliant man.
Come on,
man.
That dude is a pimp.
And you're hating your hating on that guy.
That the though.
That's a fucker.
You talk a woman,
there's a ghost in a monkey.
You're a fucking genius
and she's got to give him money.
It's a brilliant even fuck up,
but give them really to blend you with this girl looked like this.
Got To be a picture of this dummy.
Not so far.
I don't really want to see a picture.
He said,
poor guy.
His name was Wang.
Jie on one brilliant Huang h u a n g,
G.
I was in grammar school dog.
He was that little Chinese dude in the back that got.
There'll be through fucking paperclip.
Said,
look,
he's a gangster now.
He's getting his dick suck and getting paid.
Oh,
there really is funny man.
That is classic.
That's classic type Shit.
Explained the ghost in her vagina were preventing her boss from falling in love
with her.
Oh my God.
Check this.
So she must've come to him and said,
I want my boss to fall in love with me.
And so.
So she was a conniver man.
So he convinced her because the ghosts in her vagina were preventing her boss
from falling in love with her.
Holy Shit goes that he can easily catch with his penis.
Did you fucking arrest that guy?
Come on man,
because they don't have high five there.
That's rude.
Arresting this guy for that is rude that you should be able to go to go to court
and say,
well,
your honor,
what I told her was that her vagina was haunted and the only way she's going to
be able to steal her boss away from his wife is if she let me fuck her and catch
the goes with my Dick.
Get the fuck out of my court.
You'd be like,
get your lunchbox and get the fuck out.
You want to sue him for what you.
You thought that was true?
You thought really?
Who's going to get the the ghost out with his Dick?
Get the fuck out.
You call the cops and tell them this shit.
Straight face.
Listen,
I got arrested.
A Guy,
he stuck his dick in my fucking ghost in the fucking totally lied to me and I
guess it's the money.
It was the 3000,
250 bucks.
No problem right there.
But meanwhile,
how can they prove it?
She probably wrote a check.
I can improve it.
How can they prove that he didn't get the ghost out?
Smell it.
ECTOPLASM.
Smell.
If it smells like it can be rigged game though.
She waits right to you.
Starting.
She farts are in your face.
No,
it's a fucking crazy world out there though.
You can talk people into anything.
I'll never forget.
I forgot.
I found out about Nirvana.
I was out where this dude's house that I used to buy stolen radios from.
There's this one dude.
If you needed a radio back then when I didn't understand Karma,
you know you need to radio from your car.
You can get one from this kid who always had radios.
Then he would just somehow or another get and you didn't ask any questions,
but you knew they were stolen.
Were over his house and he was into music.
This kid,
it was just a bad kid,
you know,
whatever.
Bad suburban kid.
Not too bad.
We went over his house and he goes,
this is going to change me music.
And so what is it?
He goes,
it's called fucking Nirvana.
And he starts playing it and he goes,
all those hairbands,
those guys are fucked.
And he played this shit.
I was like,
wow.
Like you just nailed it.
Like this kid nailed it in his,
in his bedroom in Newton,
Massachusetts.
Like right when the nevermind came out.
This kid nailed it.
He just was an emphasis of thief.
He was like,
this is,
this is going to change.
This goes,
guys are fucked.
It was that obvious though was stat obvious.
Danny boy played it for me first and we were both like,
yeah,
they draws drunk.
There's only been a few times.
And like musical history when someone hits some new levels of something we had
never seen it before.
And when Nirvana came out that was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Undeniable talent is undeniable uniqueness.
The power of their songs.
Song after song.
Different.
Honest though.
Yeah.
Oh,
totally honest.
Raw.
And like at this insane heroin way.
Insane heroin.
Honesty spawned by the punk movement.
Is that what is some chains chains?
They were,
they were,
they were more on the metal side to me.
But like they were definitely of that grunge metal movement,
like soundgarden rocked out a little harder.
You know that song,
them bones,
Jesus Christ that makes you feel like you're dying when you're listening to it
shows a beach.
There was a dude who is sad.
He that motherfucker understood that he was dying.
When he wrote that song,
he understood that he was on that path when he wrote that song.
I don't think lane rope tows.
He just sang it.
I think Jerry Cantrell wrote all that stuff.
Wow.
I'm pretty sure whatever.
There may be a few that I'm wrong on,
but at the bulk and the tempera form that what I'm saying is like the way layne
staley hit notes like it made you like,
it made you feel that you were dying.
Like that song going to end up a big old pile.
Them bones like that screaming was like Jesus Christ.
I remember the first time I saw a man in the box,
like on MTV.
It was like,
what the hell is that?
God Damn.
Those guys were intense.
It was crazy.
And that kind of.
I had a night with that dude and another guy,
layne staley.
Yeah,
I did.
It was good to know.
We just
this promoter in Philly,
this,
this place,
I believe it was the electric factory,
like thousand Cedar Club,
something like that.
He booked it twice in one night.
He did two shows.
He didn't.
Allison changed show early,
kicked everybody out.
Then did the house paint show holy shit out to place twice in one night.
But we all,
because we were all at the same hotel,
so like we saw these guys.
We were coming back from hotel me and Dj Alito and they were like,
yeah.
We're like,
Hey,
what's up?
We're going to go up to the room,
smoke one party a little bit.
They were like,
all right.
We came up,
him and his buddy,
they came up and they sat at the table and we're rolling joints and we're
talking all this shit and like me and lethal and just rolling all joint after
joint,
throwing them on the table and then we stopped and we go to light one and both
the dudes are sitting there just completely knotted out cold.
Wow.
Cigarette's burned into their fingers.
I can.
We were like,
what the fuck was.
We weren't really hit.
We were kind of naive,
you know what I mean?
We were like,
didn't realize they were on heroin by that time we had,
but it was like,
you know,
the whole side.
And they were just like,
wow,
looking sniffing or smoking shit out of a
foil like Pine Hall.
No,
we haven't done that before.
We really joyous man.
You know,
he didn't even realize they were doing.
It was like it was done.
They were only in our presence for the matter,
like 15 minutes.
Oh Shit.
Itunes or recording to server,
get the fuck outta here.
Server.